moi j'ai 24 ans et avant j'étais
journaliste à la radio pendant trois ans
et en fait y arrive de l'année que
j'aimais beaucoup
c'était l'hiver comme ça ça paraît un
peu étonnant mais en fait c'était la
période où je me sentais la plus utile
parce que les personnes qui m'écoutait
avait besoin de certaines informations
vous savez c'est ce moment vous voulez
en direction de la station de ski ça
fait des heures que vous êtes dans votre
voiture
la glacière évident le thermos et froid
vos amis commencent un petit peu à vous
énerver dans la voiture et vous avez
envie de sauter dans la poudreuse et de
boire un bon verre de vin chaud en
terrasse et à ce moment là vous avez
envie de savoir si la neige est bonne la
haut et dans combien de temps vous allez
arriver et sortir de ces bouchons et
c'est normal d'avoir venant de ces
informations la situation dérangeante
solutions pratiques et immédiate mais
pour des reportages sur l'économie la
politique l'environnement difficile pour
moi de mesurer l'impact sur les
auditeurs et leur action
une fois leur poste de radio est un et
au final une question quel était mon
utilité
les trois quarts de l'année et pourtant
moi quand j'étais jeune j'étais plus
jeune
l'une de mes principales motivations
pour faire ce métier
c'était de me sentir utile pour les
autres hélas la plupart du temps je me
sentais frustré et puis la formation
aujourd'hui c'est comme un refrain qui
cumule les fausses notes première fausse
note c'est la densité d'information
deuxième fausse note c'est la difficulté
de s'engager
la densité de l'information la formation
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas seulement la
circulation la météo évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus large que ça c'est une loi
des élections des conflits les
mouvements sociaux bien plus que des
fois on se retrouve un petit peu noyé
moi j'adore passer des heures à chercher
des informations
j'adore suivra le texte sur twitter
passé dans l'article à un ami
sur facebook je fais passer des heures
mais c'est ma passion c'est mon métier
j'adore ça et tout le monde n'a pas le
temps de faire ça et on ne sait pas
forcément où aller chercher le problème
c'est que quand on est mal informé on ne
peut pas bien s'engager
est ce que quelqu'un dans cette salle
serait expliqué précisément la guerre
ancien compliqué est ce que quelqu'un
dans cette salle serait lui dire comment
sont utilisées nos impôts concrètement
qui dans cette salle sera expliqué à son
voisin les intérêts l'enjeu des
élections européennes
c'est mon petit fils et puis il ya la
difficulté de s'engager pour aujourd'hui
l'engagement ça se limite à un lien au
début de l'article qui renvoie une
pétition une manifestation mais si comme
moi vous avez la mémoire un peu courte
vous lisez l'article ça vous perturbe
peut-être vous leur servait et puis dix
minutes plus tard vous êtes passé
chose il ne s'est rien passé moi
aujourd'hui j'estime qu'on doit pas être
experts dans tous les domaines non de
pouvoir s'informer rapidement simplement
espère en la possibilité de s'engager
après vous connaissez le principe
d'action réaction
moi j'aimerais créer un nouveau refrain
informations réaction action aujourd'hui
ce refrain il est en outre vous savez
par le son est coupé et c'est bien
dommage
visualiser cette salle tous un jour on a
eu envie de donner notre avis à notre
patron à un média 1 et vu et pourtant
50% d'entre nous la moitié de ça ne l'a
pas fait l'envi mais pas l'action est la
raison principale c'est que toutes ces
personnes se sont dit que la ravine
n'allait pas être prises en compte
c'est 50%
c'est le résultat d'un sondage qui a été
mené auprès des français récemment
d'après le même sondage la plupart des
français estiment que les citoyens ont
un rôle important et que les élus
devraient davantage les écouter dans
leur prise de décision
et puis dans d'autres pays l'engagement
associatif bénévole il existe il
augmente chaque année
cet engagement il concerne plus d'un
jeune sur trois et quand on s'engage ce
n'est pas vain moi je pense aux
pétitions typiquement et notamment à une
petite foule qui m'a beaucoup marqué
c'est celle d'un homme qui s'appelle
patrice à paris et qui voyait devant
chez lui des réfugiés
qui manquait de nourriture et patrice à
la cantine le midi dans un des hôpitaux
de paris où il travaillait il voyait des
tonnes de nourriture
allez à la poubelle des plateaux repas
qui n'était pas fini patrice c'est une
situation qui l'a perturbé qu'il a
trouvé absurde
il s'est dit il faudrait distribuer les
surplus alimentaire aux réfugiés
patrice il a embarqué des milliers de
personnes avec lui cinquante cinq mille
personnes ont signé la pétition qu'il
avait créé patrice il a réussi à obtenir
une réponse des hôpitaux de paris pour
la mise en place de circuits courts
entre les associations des deux réfugiés
et les hôpitaux de paris pour la
redistribution des surplus alimentaires
et moi quand je vois le potentiel de ce
type d'engagement
j'arrive à imaginer tout ce qu'on
pourrait déployer en généralisant le
refrain informations réaction action
si vous voulez moi j'ai souvent vu les
problèmes mais sans doute revoir les
solutions
c'est pas une question de fainéantise ou
de manque de volonté c'est vraiment une
question de regard comme lorsqu'on
oublie ses lunettes et qu'on voit un peu
fou je suis convaincu que chaque citoyen
si les mieux informés s'il en a envie
peu mieux s'engager s'il est bien
accompagné alors maintenant on fait quoi
il ya un exemple que je trouve très
intéressant c'est une journaliste
américaine qui a écrit un article au
lendemain de l'élection de donald trump
est allé à tous ses lecteurs qu'ils
étaient choqués tristes dans la
compréhension face à
résultat elle aura dit vous pouvez
transformer vos sentiments positifs et
cette journaliste
elle leur a proposé plusieurs actions
s'étaient donné de l'argent à une
association
c'était rejoindre l'une d'elles pour
lutter contre le racisme les violences
policières ou encore aider à
l'organisation des élections pour
accompagner les autres citoyens
son article les trouvais intéressant
pertinents mais je pense qu'il aurait pu
être encore plus percutant et je pense
que ça passe par facebook facebook en
france c'est 30 millions d'utilisateurs
la moitié de nos pays et sur facebook
moi je ne connais aucune autre
plateforme qui rassemble autant de
personnes dans notre pays
facebook en france ces neuf jeunes sur
dix et puis entendu que facebook
il y a facebook messenger sais pas si
vous connaissez c'est la possibilité de
discuter sur facebook avec ses amis et
sur messenger vous pouvez aussi discuté
avec des bottes les bottes sont des
robots qui repose sur l'intelligence
artificielle et avec eux vous pouvez
discuter ils vont nous ils répondent à
vos questions
et parmi tous ses potes il y en a qui
permettra bientôt je vous ne vous
enfermez pour davantage vous engager ce
vote nous sommes en train de le
développer avec mes collègues
il s'appelle et le bot et c'est la
dernière création de notre start up
box.com
alors comment ça marche concrètement et
bien ce bot
reprenons l'exemple de la guerre en
syrie vous prenez votre téléphone vous
dit bonjour bottes et vous lui demandez
pas j'ai pas compris c'est vrai que
c'est un fou il se passe beaucoup de
choses j'ai envie de savoir ce qui se
passe vraiment et qu'on m'explique ce
bot qui va
des informations il va vous dire en quoi
ça vous concerne est ce que vous pouvez
faire concrètement à votre échelle ce
pote on veut vraiment qui s'adapte à
chacun de nos utilisateurs
on n'a pas tous le même rythme de vie
moi par exemple j'adore ma forme et le
matin dans le métro et le soir juste
avant de dormir bien calée entre mais
aurélie par contre il ya des mondes la
journée où je n'aime pas trop qu'on
dérangé par exemple en plein milieu
d'après-midi quand je suis en réunion
avec mes collègues et j'ai besoin de
concentration
tous on a un rythme différent notre
botte on veut vraiment qu'ils s'adaptent
à vous comme foncez pas absolument
géniaux qui épouse la forme la vie pour
qu'on dorme le mieux possible
chez vox touareg
nous sommes en train de développer le
premier bottes qui vous pousse à agir
avec cet outil nous allons généraliser
le refrain informations réaction action
nous allons enfin pouvoir sortir du
câlin avec cet outil nous allons pouvoir
nous informer partout et puis nous
impliquer nous indigner passer à
l'action
concrètement tous les jours toute
l'année pour nous sentir utile et pas
seulement en hiver
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]